[Aplausos]
[Música]
esta es la pregunta del millón de
dólares puede sobrevivir la economía de
ucrania a una invasión rusa o dicho de
otra forma como afectaría una invasión
rusia a los ucranianos que viven en los
territorios no ocupados podrían mantener
sus empresas o se verían relegados a
subsistir me explico en estos momentos
todas las opciones están abiertas putin
no se ha limitado a invadir el este de
ucrania sino que ha llegado hasta la
capital es decir hasta kiev qué
significa todo esto pues lo cierto es
que no lo sabemos puede que rusia y
ucrania terminen una guerra abierta que
se prolongaría durante años o tal vez
terminen en un 'alto el fuego' en visual
político no tenemos una bola de cristal
pero si tenemos otra cosa mucha memoria
porque si mis queridos amigos de la
comunidad de visual política existe un
precedente muy parecido a ucrania un
país que también ha sido invadido por
putin de qué país estamos hablando
exacto de georgia
[Música]
y no no me refiero al estado de eeuu
sino al país georgia con capital en
tíflis significa esto que los ucranianos
van a correr la misma suerte que los
georgianas no pero nadie puede negar que
hay un montón de similitudes además
georgia puede enseñar un montón de
elecciones si sois nómadas digitales o
estáis ligeramente interesados en este
estilo de vida seguramente hayáis oído
mencionar este país miles de veces
porque se trata de uno de los destinos
de moda para pequeños emprendedores y
nómadas digitales y en fin os tengo que
confesar que aquí en visual político
tenemos un cariño muy especial este país
y diréis por qué pues porque nuestro
primer vídeo viral fue un vídeo que
dedicamos a georgia corría el año 2016
cuando todavía no teníamos ni mil
suscriptores y en fin que nos llevó a
decir entonces que la comunidad de
visual política iba a ser tan grande que
hoy en día hasta tendríamos camisetas
por cierto queréis haceros con nuestro
merchandising exclusivo pues no está a
la venta la única forma de conseguirlo
es entrando en nuestro patrón vamos que
estas camisetas que veis son exclusivas
de verdad y por cierto todos los diseños
están hechos por nosotros dicho de otra
forma que si entráis a formar parte del
patrón de visual polític no sólo vais a
ayudar a que este proyecto siga adelante
con toda la independencia y el rigor que
tanto os gusta sino que además
accederemos a merchandising realmente
exclusivo y a nuestra newsletter de
análisis político que es un auténtico
lujazo pero volvamos con nuestra
historia de hoy
lo cierto es que georgia es uno de los
países más interesantes del mundo
especialmente por este señor que veis en
pantalla
os presento al ex presidente de georgia
mijaíl saakashvili si este hombre
hubiera nacido en san francisco os
aseguro que tendría por lo menos tres
series de netflix y dos de la hb o hecho
creo que es el único político de la
historia que puede presumir de haber
ocupado cargos de responsabilidad
política en dos países distintos uno es
georgia y el otro cuadri es que es uno
dos tres
exacto ucrania tras gobernar georgia
saakashvili consiguió la ciudadanía
ucraniana y llegó a ser gobernador de la
región de odessa absolutamente todo en
la vida de este hombre es digno de
película podrá gustarnos más o menos
pero en nadie absolutamente nadie puede
negar que es un personaje único en la
historia un señor que levanta pasiones y
odios y diréis quién es su mayor hater
exacto vladimir putin y ojo porque esta
vez hablamos de odio de verdad atentos
porque esto es una declaración textual
algún día colgaré a saakashvili de las
pelotas
[Música]
bueno si pudiste dice eso ya puedes
empezar a asustar pero
[Aplausos]
y diréis pero porque tanto odio pues lo
cierto es que la quinta parte del
territorio de georgia está ocupada por
rusia y así lleva desde el año 2008
cuando estalló la guerra de georgia
habéis oído bien podríamos decir que
georgia es como una ucrania en miniatura
así que la pregunta es cómo es posible
que haya tantos nómadas digitales que se
marchan a vivir a un país invadido ha
sobrevivido a georgia la invasión rusa
que elecciones puede aprender ucrania de
esta historia y qué errores ha cometido
georgia hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un poco
de historia
[Música]
la idea de borat
ya lo hemos dicho si eres un nómada
digital probablemente hayas oído hablar
de georgia o incluso estés ahí en estos
momentos viendo nuestro vídeo georgia
sigue siendo un país pobre pero a la vez
han llegado a pedir entrar en la unión
europea todo esto es una historia de
cuento de hadas si tenemos en cuenta que
hace 20 años georgia era como decirlo
habéis visto curet pues al lado de
georgia a la aldea de borat parecería
manhattan este país era la
cristalización de todos los estereotipos
que tengáis en la cabeza de una
república exsoviética mafias corrupción
y muchísima pobreza durante la guerra
fría georgia era una república dentro de
la unión soviética pero en 1991
declararon la independencia y entraron
en guerra con moscú al igual que está
ocurriendo en ucrania georgia tiene dos
provincias cuya población se siente más
rusa que georgiana en este caso hablamos
de osetia del sur y abjasia desde 1992
son dos regiones de esas que aparecen
sombreadas con rayitas en los mapas y
grace y que ha pasado en el resto del
país pues para ser honestos nada bueno
muchos de vosotros pensaréis que el fin
del comunismo fueron buenas noticias
para todos en la unión soviética sin
embargo georgia es uno de los casos
donde no fue así
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea en sólo 10
años el pib de georgia cayó a menos de
la mitad es más este país sigue
sufriendo una pérdida de población
brutal en 1989 georgia tenía cerca de 5
millones de habitantes ahora están en 37
millones de personas y grace pero como
es posible que las cosas vayan tan mal
en este lugar pensando bien en los años
90 a georgia se convirtió en el campo de
cultivo perfecto para mafias y políticos
corruptos pero no sólo eso la poca
industria que había en el país venía
desde moscú de la época soviética una
vez se independizaron todas las fábricas
cerraron para que os hagáis una idea
durante los años 90 la principal
exportación georgiana era la chatarra
que habían dejado los soviéticos en las
fábricas siderúrgicas sí sí habéis oído
bien la principal exportación de georgia
eran los trozos de metal que quedaban en
las fábricas que se acababan de cerrar
con esto ya os podéis imaginar cómo
estaba el país por otra parte tampoco es
nada que os sorprenda hablamos de la
región del cáucaso todos los países y
las regiones de esta zona están igual o
peor por estas zonas donde está a
azerbaiyán armenia chechenia vamos que
estamos hablando de una de las zonas más
oscuras del planeta como diría en
español de españa más yungas sin embargo
el destino de georgia cambió para
siempre en el año 2003 y diréis pero qué
ocurrió en este momento pues ahora mismo
lo vamos a ver
[Música]
la revolución de las rosas
hay momentos en la historia en los que
contra todo pronóstico una persona lo
cambia todo y este es uno de esos casos
y si la persona de la que estamos
hablando es mijail sakashvili alguno
dirá que este vídeo es una alabanza o
una loa la figura de este hombre pero
realmente si dejamos a un lado la
opinión que se pueda tener sobre este
señor nadie puede negar que lo ha vivido
absolutamente todo objetivamente este
señor ha cambiado completamente la
historia de su país y os lo digo en
serio aquí en visual política hemos
analizado ya un montón de países y de
figuras políticas y aún así la vida de
saakashvili es una película en el vídeo
de hoy solamente vamos a contaros una
pequeña parte y es que en el año 2003
mijaíl saakashvili era un abogado que
había estudiado en eeuu ahí es donde se
convirtió en el mayor defensor de
occidente y el libre mercado si mis
queridos amigos liberales y libertarios
que veis este canal si hay un héroe del
estado mínimo y del liberalismo ese no
es otro que mijaíl saakashvili
en 2003 lideró lo que podríamos llamar
la revolución liberal más exitosa de los
últimos 100 años la revolución de las
rosas vale hay que reconocer una cosa la
forma en la que llegó al poder no fue lo
más democrática del mundo pero seamos
claros recordar que cree [ __ ] en algo
así como la aldea de borat pero versión
peor en cualquier caso saakashvili llegó
al poder con una promesa convertir a
georgia en el paraíso del libre mercado
eso significa lucha contra la corrupción
impuestos bajos y acuerdos de libre
comercio con todo el mundo para que os
hagáis una idea sus reformas fueron tan
radicales e incluso el fondo
monetariointernacional dejó de prestar
dinero al país y grace pero por qué pues
porque pensaban que con unos impuestos
tan bajos como querían poner serían
incapaces de devolver los préstamos sin
embargo adivináis qué es lo que pasó
pues atentos a esta gráfica
[Música]
aquí lo tenéis georgia tiene uno de los
sistemas fiscales más minimalistas del
mundo recordáis nuestro vídeo de estonia
pues georgia tiene un modelo casi
idéntico al de estonia a esto hay que
sumarle los acuerdos de libre comercio y
la limpieza del estado para que os
hagáis una idea sakashvili llegó a
despedir a más de 16.000 policías
corruptos en los primeros años de su
mandato y sí ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando muchos todo esto suena como el
sueño húmedo como la gran fantasía de
visual político verdad pues si tenéis
razón por supuesto que a muchos les
parecerá un programa horrible de
gobierno pero lo cierto es que los datos
hablan por sí solos entre 2004 y 2007 el
pib de georgia crecía un 35% y la
inversión internacional se volcó en el
país
[Música]
por poner un ejemplo de inversión
extranjera fue en el año 2007 cuando
ferrero que es la marca que fabrica la
nutella abrió una planta en el país para
poder procesar las avellanas y es que si
una de las principales exportaciones de
georgia son los frutos secos eso y el
vino porque georgia es conocida como el
lugar donde nació el vino así que en
pocos años este país se dedicó a
exportar avellanas y vino como si no
hubiera mañana y ya se lo que estáis
pensando mucho es oye esto es sector
primario donde está la industria donde
están los servicios pues si tenéis razón
pero pensad que georgia venía de ser la
aldea de borat lo importante es que el
país aunque seguía siendo pobre y
subdesarrollado estaba en la senda
correcta era la estrella del cáucaso y
entonces es cuando ocurrió la desgracia
atentos
[Música]
las primeras víctimas de putin
otra de las promesas de saakashvili al
llegar al poder fue la reunificación
nacional porque como os podéis imaginar
a los georgianas no les hacían nada de
gracia tener a dos provincias que de
facto eran independientes y que
aparecían con sombreado de rayitas en el
mapa puede sonar un poco raro pero pese
a ser un país tan pequeño con menos de
cuatro millones de habitantes georgia
tiene varios idiomas y etnias distintas
y hay dos regiones donde el georgiano no
lo quieren ver ni en pintura
osetia del sur y abjasia
y que tienen en común estas regiones
pues aparte de no tener mucha simpatía
por georgia tienen un enorme cariño por
la madre rusia
exacto esta historia o resulta familiar
es algo casi idéntico al donbass o a
crimea pero no sólo eso como ya os
podéis imaginar es difícil declarar tu
amor eterno por el libre mercado y por
occidente sin enfadarle un poquito a
rusia especialmente cuando sakashvili
declaró su interés explícito por entrar
en la otan al igual que ha ocurrido con
ucrania el primer ataque de putin vino
por la cartera en el año 2006 rusia
ordenó un boicot comercial contra
georgia y diréis que vino después de la
cartera
exacto el ataque militar con si georgia
chocan por una región separatista en el
año 2008 un grupo de separatistas de
osetia del sur pusieron una bomba a un
grupo de soldados georgianos que en
[ __ ] había intentado negociar una
solución territorial que permitiera que
las regiones rebeldes aceptasen formar
parte de georgia pero las negociaciones
no habían funcionado y este atentado fue
la gota que colmó el vaso primero el
ejército georgiano invadió osetia del
sur y después rusia apoyó a los osetios
del sur y así es como estalló una guerra
entre rusia y georgia
igual que la guerra de ucrania rusia
también llegó hasta la capital de
georgia de hecho exactamente igual que
ha ocurrido en kiev los rusos también
bombardearon el aeropuerto de tíflis
pero no sólo eso en sólo 12 días rusia
ocupó casi todo el país incluidas las
partes con población anti rusa si esto
es lo mismo que está pasando ahora mismo
en ucrania pero con una diferencia los
georgia nos estaban en una situación
mucho peor pensadlo bien el ejército de
ucrania ha tenido casi 8 años para
prepararse para una invasión lo hemos
contado ya en muchos vídeos de visual
política sin embargo georgia es un país
más pequeño con menos ejército y en
definitiva mucho más fácil de conquistar
invadir todo a ucrania llevaría mucho
más de 12 días en cualquier caso que
creéis que pasó en georgia
[Música]
hola
en esta historia francia con nicolas
sarkozy me dio para negociar un alto al
fuego y rusia consiguió lo que quería el
control de hojas ya y el control de
osetia del sur a cambio retiraron las
tropas del resto de georgia conclusión
cuál es la situación de georgia hoy en
día pues atentos a este mapa de los
mapamundis de rusia asia y osetia del
sur son dos repúblicas independientes
sin embargo ningún otro país al menos
ningún país que no sea un paria lo
reconoce como tal así que en los
mapamundis del resto del mundo son dos
territorios de esos que están sombreados
con rayitas y efectos prácticos estas
dos repúblicas actúan como dos
provincias rusas incluso usan el rublo
como moneda de curso legal en otras
palabras que parece muy razonable pensar
que tanto donges como luhansk correrán
la misma suerte y creedme no os gustaría
vivir en estas zonas la pregunta es qué
ha pasado en el resto de georgia han
conseguido seguir con su vida pese a la
guerra con rusia pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
[Música]
/
y occidente
[Música]
en el año 2013 sacas min y perdió las
elecciones y quien diría es que le
sucedió pues atentos porque esta es una
historia de personajes cuanto menos
pintorescos el sucesor de saakashvili
fue este señor que veis en pantalla
hablamos de vitrina ivanishvili también
conocido con el apodo de boris este buen
señor hizo una auténtica fortuna
vendiendo ordenadores en rusia durante
los años 90 y diréis pero como de
grandes su fortuna pues atentos porque
se calcula que este hombre tiene una
suma de dinero equivalente a la tercera
parte de todo el pib de georgia si
habéis oído bien y después de haber
hecho tantísimo dinero en rusia volvió a
su ideología natal para probar suerte en
la política así que en 2012 creó su
propio partido al que llamó el sueño
georgiano y como os podéis imaginar con
tantísimo dinero para campaña electoral
el sueño georgiano arrasó en las
elecciones del año siguiente pero no
sólo eso tras ganar las elecciones
saakashvili fue exiliado y perdió la
nacionalidad un paréntesis saakashvili
es uno de los pocos ejemplos de una
persona que ha llegado a ser
técnicamente apátrida es decir que
durante un par de años no tuvo ninguna
nacionalidad pero eso es historia otro
vídeo que se habilitaría para varias
series de netflix
en cualquier caso desde el año 2013 el
partido de ivanishvili ha dominado la
política georgiana y diréis pero qué
ideología tiene este partido pues como
os podéis imaginar sueño georgiano es
todo lo pro ruso que puede llegar a ser
un partido en georgia es decir no mucho
como os podéis imaginar la mayoría de
los georgianos no quieren ver a rusia ni
en pintura no deja de ser el país con el
que todavía siguen en guerra sin embargo
ivanishvili es lo suficientemente pro
ruso como para lograr cosas como esta
socialista para volver a importar vino y
agua georgiana pero no os equivoquéis
georgia sigue muy lejos de la esfera de
influencia rusa sí es cierto desde el
año 2013 georgia ha vuelto a comerciar
con rusia pero no creáis que son su
único socio comercial atentos la unión
europea firmó un acuerdo de libre
comercio con georgia exacto georgia
comercia a la vez con rusia y con la
unión europea todo esto explica no sólo
el despegue de sus vinos que cada vez se
exportan más sino que también explica la
creación de un nuevo sector económico
que hace décadas era impensable en este
país el turismo
y si ya sé lo que estaréis pensando
turismo pero pero quién sería de
vacaciones un país que está en guerra
pues atentos a esta gráfica
[Música]
lo cierto es que antes de la pandemia
georgia llegó a tener casi 8 millones de
visitantes el crecimiento del turismo ha
sido casi milagroso sí es cierto que las
zonas ocupadas son peligrosas pero
ciudades como batum se han llenado de
hoteles en primera línea de costa muchos
de ellos financiados por capital
extranjero georgia se ha convertido en
un destino relativamente barato para
turistas rusos y turistas turcos sin
embargo no es oro todo lo que reluce
[Música]
sí es cierto la georgia de hoy en día
está mucho mejor que la de hace 20 años
sin embargo el país todavía mantiene un
desempleo del 17 por ciento en la última
década apenas han invertido en educación
y como resultado es difícil que surjan
empresas de alto valor añadido no hay
mano de obra bien formada eso por no
hablar de que el sistema es cada vez más
autoritario de hecho en el año 2021
metieron a saakashvili en la cárcel por
razones bastante oscuras y rusia sigue
presionando para volver a incluir a
georgia en su esfera de influencia así
que es muy difícil pensar que este país
llegue algún día a ser miembro de la
unión europea o de la otan
[Música]
ahora bien hay una cosa indudable hay
muchas muchas lecciones que se pueden
sacar de georgia así que la pregunta es
qué puede aprender ucrania de georgia es
posible que la parte oeste de ucrania se
convierta en una economía modélica que
atraiga grandes cantidades de inversión
extranjera veremos un boom del turismo
en kiev pueden surgir otras industrias
innovadoras en ucrania pese a estar en
guerra con rusia podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y como
siempre no olvidéis que aquí en visual
politics sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribiros a este canal
y darle a la campanita para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones si
se ha gustado este vídeo darle a like y
nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto
[Música]